brothers and sisters helped me on this
new project to sponsor 50 orphans
brothers and sisters inshallah it's 600
pounds a year but i wanted every one of
you guys to get involved by giving even
if it's one pound
please get involved now each other and
help us sponsor 50 orphans for an
entire year this scum dirt
i would spit in his face we need to call
out people like him
people like him should not get away with
these tweets
yeah you're supporting baby killers
occupiers
thieves you coward to hell with your ear
mobility
to hell
how can we have so many devices with so
many apps which help us monitor our
progress for our body
but none for the soul only does it
encourage you to read it tells you how
many verses you've read how many pages
you read how long you've been on it and
best of all the hasanah counter
download the qurani app now and have a
ramadan with allah subhanahu wa tala's
book like you've never had before
assalamualaikum brothers and sisters and
dear friends eid mubarak to every single
one of you guys
may allah accept your deeds
brothers and sisters this video is a
very video specifically
to a coward called sagitt it's not
the guardian apostle
this guy is he makes me sick literally
he makes me sick to my stomach
look at what he's tweeted and wallahi
you have to be an absolute scum i'm so
sorry
i think this is the best eid gift i can
give him this is the best eat gift i can
give away
i cannot have eid if i didn't do this
video here is him as you guys can see
imagine look at the audacity wow
what kind of a scum you have to be here
imagine living in london
while terrorists indiscriminately fire
thousands of rockets at your family's
neighborhood you'd expect the government
government to do every
everything in its power to find to find
and target those attackers
israel has a right to security and a
duty to defend its people just as much
as we do
this new cycle of violence is extremely
concerning the only way to build the
lasting piece is through dialogue
and the escalation you coward
you dirt of this earth why am i so harsh
recently brothers and sisters we have to
be real with ourselves
kids are being babies are being blown
blown into pieces blown
into pieces and this scum dirt
i would spit in his face
spit in his face up some bella
if i'm saying and acting like this for
the cameras i would love to
spit at this guy's face guys just
imagine let's put this into real context
imagine let's put it into now real damn
context yeah now
imagine sagitt you dog you're a dog
coward
imagine i come into your house and say
and you take me in and allow me to sleep
on the sofa
and then i say you know what you give me
the sofa but can i can i have the whole
room to myself my privacy
and you're like you know no problem and
then i come to your bedroom
and i say you know i like your bed you
know i bet it's nice and let me sleep
here
and you're like okay and you're like
should i go sleep in the uh
other in the sofa i don't know that's
mine as well and i slowly slowly
push you to the toilet you deserve the
toilet anyways
uh i think that'd be a good place for
you because uh you know
that's where you're in you can your
habitat your natural habitat
um and you say hold on a second man i
open my arms to this guy
his camera only kicked me out from he's
taken over my sofa then the room then my
bedroom
now i'm in the toilet and give me the
toilet and now you want to retaliate
and now when you retaliate i come and
bomb
kill your family members blow your
children into pieces yeah
okay and then you for example and the
u.n the u.n resolution says that
um palestinians have a right to armed
resistance
yeah armed resistance okay we're against
any kind of attack against innocents
innocence yeah innocent people period
but they have a right to armed
resistance now imagine
you are doing all of this and i defend
myself i defend myself and i am named a
terrorist
i am a terrorist guys can you fathom and
imagine
this coward and imagine this happening
in london
imagine us londoners are facing this
this coward
dog saget javed whatever the flipping
hell his name is
yeah sajid coward okay
imagine brothers and sisters and now he
dares to come and put this out
and then his next week what was his day
with today eid mubarak to all muslims
celebrating you can across the world
me to hell with your eid mubarak
to hell yeah and this shameless man
this sheamus man when trump came to the
buckingham palace they didn't even
invite you
you coward they didn't even invite you
you're shameless they don't give a damn
about you
you're sucking up them licking their
backside they don't give a damn about
you bro
they didn't even invite you that's what
they see you as their little dog
that's what they see as a little puppy
you're a little dog that's what you are
you coward you're selling yourself out
just for a few
gains in this life yeah and you're going
to lose this life which you are
literally like a dog and you're going to
lose to here after as well you shameless
man
you shame this man if i saw you in
public i would expose you intellectually
i would expose you
you coward and you're going to come here
eid mubarak you shameless man
we need to call out people like him
people like him
should not get away with these tweets
they should not
get away they need to be held
accountable for
intellectually academically they need to
be exposed
if you see this guy in the public put
your camera and say
shame on you you dirt shame on you
yeah say shame on you you coward
yeah you're supporting baby killers you
coward
yeah you're supporting baby killers
occupiers
thieves you coward
shame on you and make sure you send this
video
to his tweet i want him to see it i
would love for him and i know he will
see it send it to his tweet
spam it and i want him i know he's gonna
click it's gonna be curious what is this
and says if you're watching this shame
on you you coward
poo in your face brothers and sisters i
feel better that that's off my chest now
alhamdulillah
next time assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh